- You produce, you write songs, you act,
you do all the things.
Is there anything left?
You've had such an illustrious career.
Like, is there anything
left that you wanna do
that you haven't done yet?
- Well, first of all, that was very kind.
- [Kelly] It was honest.
- Growing up in the industry
and getting access to
so much in the studio.
- Yeah.
- I just became like a studio rat.
Like, I just loved being in there.
And I loved the creative process
and also as it pertains to harmonies,
I spent some time with four other guys
doing a lot of harmonies.
(audience cheers)
- Who are you speaking of?
By the way, y'all broke the internet
when y'all came back for the song.
- Yeah, that was fun.
That was fun.
- Yeah.
- It was kind of crazy.
Like, there's so much that just picks up
right where it left off as
far as the chemistry, but.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
Yes.
- I'm just saying.
- I don't normally, I don't want people
to think can, what is that?
Can you see that picture again?
I don't, I feel like I have a disclaimer.
Like I was having a really bad allergy day
and that's why I was
wearing the sunglasses.
I don't want, no,
but yeah, we've been in the studio,
so there may be a little.
- Okay, that's what I was gonna ask, okay.
- [Justin] Something in the future, too.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
That's exciting.
Well, we need to get to a few commercials.
Let's pass things over to Megan.
- Hi Kelly and Justin.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Justin.
- That is, I'm sorry, that is jarring.
- I didn't see it 'til just now.
- Justin, I feel like we
already know each other.
I keep this cut out in my
high school Spanish classroom.
You've been my ride or die
co-teacher for the last 18 years.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Helping me teach Spanish
verbs, conjugation, sentences.
We do it all, baby.
You even, sorry babe.
You even make sure the kids don't cheat
on tests and quizzes, thank you.
- You're just holding.
- More with Kelly and Justin after this.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Here is fine?
(audience claps)
You want met to, just my
name or you want me to put?
- I love you, Megan.
(audience laughs)
Bold.